so after two long years here we are it's
hard to believe that any of it actually
happened looking back it was two years
of unremitting never diminishing
hysteria about Russia it was a
continuous wave of panic and
superstition over unseen Slavic
interference all stoked by the very
people were told are the most rational
in our society for two years our capital
city became it became a kind of massive
CNN panel a living monument to ignorance
and dishonesty were the loudest and the
dumbest invariably got the most
attention we just lived through two full
years of that screaming threatening
surveillance character assassination
loyalty tests wild allegations of
treason and spying and betrayal from
officeholders innocent people find
themselves afraid to go to dinner scared
to send text messages or talk on the
phone for two years we lived in an
all-pervasive cult of personality
our leaders worshipped a 74 year old
federal prosecutor who almost never
spoke in public he alone was good they
told us only they could interpret his
will it was all thoroughly bizarre
demented really though nobody said so at
the time they were too afraid it seems
like a dream now which actually it was
and then if it was real
nobody colluded with Vladimir Putin
nobody changed vote totals or met
secretly in Prague or at a P tape
whatever that is there was never a rush
of conspiracy Hillary Clinton wasn't
robbed of a rightful position by Julian
Assange or Roger stone or anyone else
Hillary lost the election because she
was an entitled boor who didn't run on
anything in the end that's what Robert
Muller proved the news anchors couldn't
handle that they couldn't handle that
conclusion
it was too far from what they'd promised
their audiences for so long they were
too invested in the lies when the report
arrived in Congress this morning they
found themselves reduced to huffing and
sputtering they could admit what was in
the report well they told this Robert
Muller didn't exonerate president Trump
okay I mean that may be true but only
theologically Muller doesn't have the
power to absolve sin only God can but in
every other sense Muller's report was
exculpatory
if dozens of federal prosecutors spent
two years trying to charge you with the
crime and then found they couldn't it
would mean there wasn't any real
evidence you did it and that's what
happened here you may not like Donald
Trump but that's what we just learned
from the Muller report you would have to
be a mindless partisan to deny it a lot
of news anchors turn out to be mindless
partisans when the facts contravened the
interests of their party they deny the
facts then they attack anyone who
persists in stating the obvious out loud
so suddenly the very same people who
lied to you for two years about Russia
are demanding that under no
circumstances are you allowed to believe
anything that the Attorney General Bill
Barr might say sure Barr may look like a
conventional Republican he was a Jeb
Bush donor and everything and he does
appear to be a close personal friend of
Robert Muller's but that's why he's so
tricky it's all a ruse in fact Barr is a
putin's stooge like all the rest if you
look at his behavior it is not that of a
geriatric it is that of a partisan but
this looks like an inside job we
shouldn't take anything that Barr says
tomorrow as anything other than
performative coup Nuri his bar the
president's new fix the answer to that
seems to be yes but he becomes the first
cabinet secretary to plunge into the
deep end of trumps conspiracy pool so it
was an inside job that's the reigning
assumption in Washington somehow the
Attorney General is preventing robert
muller from concluding that donald trump
colluded with vladimir putin and from
telling the rest of us about it
how was barr doing that well it's not
clear how he's doing that but they are
no less certain that he is doing that
Michelle Goldberg of the New York Times
announced day that VARs press conference
this morning marked America's
transformation into a quote
authoritarian Hunta her colleague at the
New York Times Maggie Haberman suggested
that Trump might be a Nazi
because the White House played a song
from The Sound of Music which by the way
is an anti-nazi musical but it's still
Germanic sounding and therefore
suspicious these are hysterical children
they should not be in journalism but
they are in fact they run journalism and
they have no plans on giving up their
power the Muller report is probably the
single most humiliating thing that has
ever happened to the White House press
corps in the history of this country so
how did reporters in Washington respond
today when it finally came out well they
did what they do best they celebrated
themselves over on Sina and former Obama
official now posing as a reporter Jim
sciutto bragged the Muller report had
quote debunked all of Donald Trump's
unfair attacks on the media at Jeff
Bezos his newspaper a guy called Philip
bump was telling us that quote the vast
amount of reporting on Russia was
accurate uh-huh even they don't really
believe this they know they lied as we
told you a minute ago BuzzFeed claimed
its reporters had seen personally with
their own eyes evidence that Michael
Cohen had been instructed by Donald
Trump himself to perjure himself this
was gonna be grounds for impeachment the
editor of BuzzFeed defended that story
even after the Muller investigation took
the unusual step of publicly saying it
wasn't true BuzzFeed went all-in and
they defended it they'd seen it with our
own eyes he told us that on this set on
this show and now there's no question
about it it's over it's done it was a
lie that and so much more all lies so
what happens now that we know those were
lies what do we do with I don't know
John Brennan and James clapper the two
of them used to run our most powerful
intelligence agencies for the past
couple years they've gotten a lot richer
than they've ever been from me a peeing
about Russia on television only problem
all lies
what makes you believe that he has more
indictments because he hasn't addressed
the issues related to criminal
conspiracy as well as any individuals no
conspiracy involving the Russian and
Russia's yes yeah it is their influence
whether witting or unwitting by the by
the Russians over President Trump and
you know in the intervening year and a
half or so you know his behavior hasn't
done much at least in my mind to allay
that concern so du clapper and Brennan
get to keep their cable television
contracts probably in decadent societies
that guilty aren't punished only the
unpopular are punished over on the other
channels they're still talking about
Trump tonight of course I was talking
about themselves or their failures the
line they're quoting most is from
today's report it was apparently Trump's
response when he first learned there was
going to be a special council
investigation into Russia Oh God
he said this is terrible this is the end
of my presidency
I'm effed well as it turns out Trump was
wrong on the specifics he didn't get
indicted Muller didn't drive him from
office it wasn't the end of his
presidency
strictly speaking but as usual Trump's
instincts were clearer in fact they were
dead-on
in the ways that matter most the Russia
hoax did end his presidency in some
sense it certainly sabotage dit Mo's
investigation ended critical momentum
from the 2016 election almost
immediately momentum that every incoming
president uses to get your program
enacted to make good on the promises you
just made to voters Trump didn't have
that thanks to Russia lawmakers
including a shamefully large number of
Republicans who we really should name
but we're out of time but we will at
some point they were all much happier to
talk about Russia than about changing
the status quo in Washington something
they were benefitting from but which
Trump ran against and so they did talk
about Russia endlessly the result an
election that should have realigned our
political process and changed this
country had almost no effect
two years later virtually nothing has
changed millions are still flooding over
our border from the third world they're
encouraged by an army of nonprofits that
instruct them to subvert and mock our
laws the opioid epidemic rages on as
horrifying and horrible and destructive
as ever suicides are up our troops are
still bogged down in Syria and
Afghanistan and many other places
Goldman stacks still controls our
economy
tech companies are still spying on you
crushing your freedom of speech you can
still have your life ruined for
supporting the wrong candidate in public
or for believing there are two genders
most ominous of all and most often
ignored Americans are dying younger and
having fewer children none of this was
ever resolved none of it was ever talked
about the Russia investigation didn't
destroy trunk but it did a lot to
destroy this country